[Music]
[Applause]
talk some football Dan Graziano ESPN
national NFL Insider also hosting NFL
live today at 4 Eastern joining us here
in the man cave look at that hosting
hosting whatever they need yeah that's
Mike okay but the difference of being an
analyst and now all of a sudden you're
the host who has to tee up the analyst
yeah it depends on the show like when
I'm hosting get up that's a lot more
sort of conversational like you know you
can kind of that I think NFL live just
the way it's structured right now just
the format of the show is a little more
sort of Station to Station sort of you
know tee up the analyst and then maybe
one will follow the other that kind of
thing so just yeah it really because
does depend on the show and I think um
you know live has been Live's fun I mean
it's good I do enjoy it there's no
question about it but get up has been
where I've spent most of my time the
last couple of years and just kind of
you know you've maybe just feel more
comfortable where you spend more time so
yeah you're in this same area you just
move over a seat or two and then exactly
next thing you know you're asking
questions yeah no and that's the thing
like it's yeah I I think if you if you
do the show enough you have a feeling
like if you you know we're going to move
you over to this chair today well you
have a sense of what you would want to
be asked and how you would want to be
involved in the conversation if someone
else was hosting so yeah for sure the
big headline or at least waiting to be a
big headline is the suspensions for
gambling with the NFL
why is it vague on the on the NFL's part
of who can who can't where you can where
you can't why not just make it a blanket
nobody is allowed to gamble yeah well I
mean it's not vague it's spelled out but
it is complex right like like if you're
a player you're allowed to bet on other
sports if you're a coach or a front
office executive you're not right so why
are players a lot it wasn't collectively
bargain it's not because of the Union so
why are players allowed to bet on other
sports why are you allowed to bet from
home but not at the team facility or on
the team bus or in the team Hotel so I I
it is all spelled out it hasn't changed
in at least five years I mean the most
updated gambling policy is from 2018 and
it's the same as it was then so uh yeah
I think the league has found
I think the league and the union thought
it was all more obvious than it turned
out to be and I think that's why there's
been a little more of a re-education
effort here over the last couple of
months because they don't want to be
suspending people for the whole year I
mean that you know that's that's lousy
for the game so uh yeah it's uh I I have
not heard any talk about amending or
reforming the gambling policy but they
do want to make it clearer to the
players what is and isn't allowed and
you're talking about maybe year-long
suspensions here I don't know if they
brought Calvin Ridley to the rookie
Symposium I mean they had Peyton Manning
and Tom Brady Calvin Ridley would
resonate Oh you mean this last one yes
oh yeah yeah yes because that's what
that guy lost 11 million dollars betting
fifteen hundred dollars that's what I
because I mean when the other
suspensions hit a few months ago the
Detroit Lions once like like Calvin
really just happened like how can this
not be fresh in your mind I mean you
know Calvin Ridley is a big enough name
that did not get ignored and everybody
knows he got suspended for a whole year
so uh yeah it's uh it's it's alarming
for sure and I do I mean the league has
started to kind of get out there and try
and get in front of these guys and say
Here's the rules in case you didn't
already know but I remember talking to
the players union after the lion
suspensions came down you know do you
feel like you guys are doing yes we are
doing enough we talked to these guys
multiple times a year we lay it out if
these guys are not doing this because
they don't know the policy they're doing
it because they thought they'd get away
with it so uh that's that's the
perspective from the people who are in
charge well wait until it's a
quarterback right because these These
are guys who are on the periphery you
know they're the backup linebacker kick
returner you know you get a quarterback
in there now all of a sudden remember
when Tony Romo wanted to have a oh the
fantasy thing the fantasy thing in Vegas
but that was right before this sort of
tidal wave of like you know a legalized
gambling state by state and also sort of
the NFL's Embrace of before the NFL
realized how much money they were going
to make on this is the NFL hypocritical
how so in handing out punishment while
making money off of gambling yeah I
think it's important that that you that
you police your players and your
personnel in terms of their gambling
habits because you do not want to go
down that road of inside information
right and now you have these guys might
have an advantage uh and that might
affect other people's ability to gamble
and make money so I do think it's I
think it's fair to hold the people that
work in the NFL and play in the NFL to a
little bit of a higher standard right
than the people you're advertising to
right if you're using gambling so I do
think there is there is reason and
incentive for the league to take a
little bit of a stronger stance with
their own Personnel uh than they would
expect from the general public that's
that's consuming their advertising Dan
Graziano ESPN national NFL Insider
hosting NFL live today at four Eastern
I don't know how well you know the
makeup of this Jets team now I know
covering them for a long long time in
the New York media but you bring in
Aaron Rodgers and you got a young team
expectation level is really high yeah so
they're not a curiosity cute story now
it's your playoffs and you know maybe
deep in how does Hard Knocks affect that
I always feel like teams are
overreacting when they don't want to do
Hard Knocks because I've been to
training camps where there's been hard
knocks and there's more cameras right
like but it's not they're not like
there's not a camera right over you as
you're trying to catch the ball in
practice you know what I mean like it's
I don't think it's as big a deal I think
I think it's about teams and you know
coaches and front offices wanting to
sort of control the flow of news right
which you know and now you're like well
we have cameras here something might get
out that we otherwise might not have
wanted to even though they I'm sure they
have total approval they do they have
total control so I just think it's a
matter of this is this is one other
thing we don't want to have to deal with
it takes away time from what but I I
don't I do not believe it matters that
much uh the Lions last year went all in
I mean you could tell they were loving
every second of it and they had that's
the coach who embraced it yes I mean
that's the difference but that's a
difference and they didn't have a star
player like Aaron Rodgers right who
might go who by the way uh is liable to
maybe say something non-football related
that makes news right and so uh yeah I
think that's that is that is a little
bit of a concern for them I don't know
that it needs to be the Lions had a fine
season last year I mean they were this
close to making the playoffs I don't
think there's a correlation between
Doing Hard Knocks and having a
disappointing season I think the Jets
will be fine if that's how it ends up
are you all in on the Jets here
the Jets have decided that they were
Aaron Rodgers away from being a Super
Bowl contending team right they went
seven seven and ten last year with
quarterback play that was not just bad
was actively harmful to their chances of
winning the games right so if you have a
guy and who's just competent you could
see getting to 9-10 wins if you have
Aaron Rodgers playing at the MVP level
he was at two three years ago you could
see getting to 13 wins right so uh I
think my question is are they right are
they right about how good their roster
already was absent Aaron Rodgers are a
confident quarterback uh The Tackle
situation is a little bit concerning
because they're counting on guys that
haven't been available Makai beckton was
a top 10 pick if he plays like that
they're probably going to be great but
he's only played one game the last two
years so uh that there are question
marks about it and Rogers is 39 like
it's not you know he he shows up to OTAs
and he pulls a calf muscle on the first
day I don't think that's going to
continue to bother him into the season
but it's an alarm Bell right like it
reminds you that the guy we just brought
in is not 25 years old like he might be
more liable to get her we might have to
be more careful with him so all in in
that conference reference in that
Division I can't get all the way there
on the Jets but I do expect them to be a
good team it's weird that I thought that
they overachieved while under achieving
greatly at the quarterbacking position
yeah like I thought that they they
weren't a seven-win team but they won
seven games and they did that in spite
of their quarterback but I thought the
other players sort of overachieved just
a little bit so it was a weird feeling
that I had with them not that man
imagine if they had a you know a
competent quarterback I mean they may be
a 10-win team here they may be I mean
they they may also like everything
breaks right and he plays out of his
mind and becton plays 17 games and looks
like a top 10 you know you know they
have the offensive rookie of the year
they have the defensive rookie there
they get Quinn and Williams contract
figured out I mean the defense does look
really good so there's reason to be
optimistic I just think that the AFC is
just going to be you know like a knife
fight like I mean there's so many good
teams there's so many great quarterbacks
like I I just don't know that in the AFC
East that that's going to produce a
12-13 win team given how good everybody
is are you more sold on the Eagles
repeating or the Niners repeating their
success well I have to say the Niners
because no one has repeated as NFC East
Champion in 19 years right like that is
and I when my first job at ESPN was the
NFC East blogger remember they had
division bloggers so I mean I've I've
lived it I've seen it weird stuff
happens like a couple you go back was it
three years ago the Eagles were
defending Champions everything looked
good Carson Wentz was real like Carson
once forgot how to play football like
the eagles just bottomed out that was
the year that Washington won it at seven
and nine and there was no reason for the
Eagles not to repeat but like dark
Forces are at work in the NFC East that
prevent it from happening so I can't I
can't in good conscience knowing this
predict an eagles repeat I don't have
another good reason not to
but something always happens I'm telling
you something always happens they laugh
at me when I say it on shows and then at
the end of the year no Dan was right
again
it's weird I don't know it doesn't I
mean I'm supposed to be able to break it
down and tell you like something's weird
in the NFC East yeah you're too measured
you gotta have hot takes and what's
wrong with you dark Forces at work is
not hot enough I thought I thought that
was pretty good I'm not hearing that
everywhere else uh yeah the Eagles were
uh what they were healthy last year you
don't get necessarily the same injury
luck you're over you know I don't know
there's the Cowboys are probably good
I I don't know something will happen I'm
telling you yeah it just feels like the
NFC is top heavy where is the AFC top
head a little Fuller you say Eagles
Niners I think not enough people are
paying attention to Seattle I think
Seattle might have a really good team
this year I I don't think what Geno
Smith did was necessarily a fluke yeah I
think he's that kind of player now and
what they have around him looks really
really good and then you know the other
two divisions
everyone's gonna pick the Lions to win
the the north the last time the Lions
won their division was 1993. like let's
see it right like I believe they're good
I think they'll be good but boy oh boy
like that's a lot of losing that they've
done a lot of so if the culture has
really turned around under Campbell they
look like they should be the favorites
there and you can you know flip a
four-sided coin in the uh in the NFC
South covering the New York media you
know we all have like scars horror
stories do you have one that sticks out
that a moment incident run-in that you
had in New York yeah probably I was just
I was just telling Paul I was at that
Mike Messina game in Fenway Park uh
where he was a strike away from a
perfect game that was a Sunday night
baseball game and you know like we're
writing for newspapers like you had yeah
had the game story written it was Mike
Messina throws a perfect game and you
had to file it as soon as it ended now
all of a sudden there's a guy on base
it's one nothing they could lose like
that was why so baseball writing was
just crazy like from from that
standpoint uh in terms of a horror story
you weren't running into badly you
weren't running into crazy Yankee
managers like I was no we had Tori yeah
Victoria was very measured yeah he
yelled at me one time it was um
so we had these fights about access you
know I was I was involved in the New
York baseball writers chapter and you
know teams were closing the clubhouses
for meetings at times that were supposed
to be media access times and at one
point I sent a letter to the
commissioner's office about Tori doing
it too many times and he came storming
out the next day into the did you send a
letter dropping f-bombs all over the did
you send a letter but in other words I
don't give you guys enough bleeping time
out here every single day blah blah and
it was it was intense and I I think Joe
it's a it's a clerical matter if there's
a stack of letters like this on the
commissioner's desk at the end of the
year about you closing the clubhouse
you're going to hear from them if it's
one letter you're not we got to make
sure and log it and he got it like
instantly like I saw his face changing
all right that makes sense next time can
you talk to me first sure no problem Joe
but he's still he still kept doing it I
remember going out there and Billy
Martin was the manager that's a little
different yeah yeah and
you know I'd smell alcohol in his breath
yeah yeah we did a very different time
yes and and I was there when he got
fired I was there when he got rehired uh
I was there Mattingly's rookie season
like you're just and I'm a kid from a
small town in Ohio next thing I know I'm
at Yankee Stadium and you know we're
getting yelled at for walking on the
grass yes like you couldn't walk on the
grass during BP yeah you had to stay off
the grass that Steinbrenner had would
have guys I don't know if they had
rifles but it felt like they probably
they were watching but I'm sure he in a
meeting Steinbrenner asked like could we
have rifles no you know I I think I mean
my best manager stories are Jim Leland
when I covered the Marlins down in
Florida like the 97 98 Marlins like he
was I mean he was
because because he went down there
signed a five-year contract everything
was good halfway through the year they
told him like at the end of the year
we're going to sell the team and trade
everybody so he sent his family back
home he slept in his office he drank
like a fish like it was just and he was
just you know all over the map
emotionally about it and
they won the world
winning the World Series yeah he was he
was a character man uh the bills
situation yeah bringing it back to
football with Sean McDermott yeah
getting a contract extension what if
they bow out early
well I think the the belief they have in
McDermott as the guy who's kind of
helped build what they have now right I
mean they you remember what the bills
were right when McDermott got there they
hadn't been to the playoffs in 17 years
in a league where there's five new
playoff teams every year the Bills had
gone 17 years so the fact that he's now
a regular in the playoffs shows you that
he's put something together that that um
that they obviously have a lot of belief
in and faith in and a lot of gratitude
for so no I think look I don't think
he's a coach that is a Bad season away
from the hot seat I think he's seen as a
guy that that you know it was him that
brought Brandon Bean in like like
McDermott has a lot of sway over what
goes on there uh so yeah I think it
would have to they'd have to fall on
some pretty hard times in order for him
to end up in trouble it just felt like
that the last two years there was so
much pressure that Josh Allen was taking
the next step and the bills were taken
the next step and I I just thought they
were putting too much pressure on him
yeah and asking him to do much because I
too much because I thought they were
one-dimensional yeah and offensively you
mean yeah yeah no running game and then
day ball leaves you go to the Giants so
Ken Dorsey his first year as offensive
coordinator is a disappointment so he's
feeling some heat yeah
um so yeah I mean they're they're you
know I think they're still really good
right but what are they going to be
offensively obviously Stefan Diggs is a
little annoyed about some things that
went on in the offense last year and
wants to see it it be different but uh
yeah it's a big it's an important year
for Dorsey it's an important year for
Allen they they are in a window right
now where they should be competing for
Super Bowl titles and they haven't
gotten to one yet does anything change
with the running back position on how
the running back position can get paid
financially I don't think so because
nothing's going to change in terms of uh
you know the wear and tear those guys
endure nothing's going to change in
terms of looking at replaceability the
Chiefs just won the the Super Bowl the
seventh round rookie at running back I
mean and you see that all the time right
you can find
you can find production at running back
in the later rounds I think what's going
to change you see these two guys who won
the first round this year Robinson to
Atlanta and Gibbs to Detroit I think
you're going to see the way they're used
be important right like they're going to
be all over the field they're going to
be lined up they're going to catch the
ball like they're going to be third down
weapons that kind of thing so maybe you
get to a point where a guy pops and he
is a Christian McCaffrey type right in
terms of how he's used not necessarily
as good as McCaffrey but in terms of how
he's used and then maybe that guy gets
paid but the grind it out between the
tackles running back the the Derrick
Henry Style guy first of all there
aren't many of them anyway and second of
all I just don't think teams want to
invest because they don't last and
because you can find guys that can do it
for a lot cheaper all the time so no
what could change
would be if they reduce the length of
rookie contracts from four years to
three that would help running backs I
think but you know the next CBA is seven
years away so I don't I don't see that
happening and anytime soon that would
help any of these current guys and it
feels like you got to be a hybrid you
have to have one player who does two
things that it has to be Christian
McCaffrey Alvin Kamara uh Debo Samuel
like we can you do a couple of things
but the days of being a battering ram it
feels like those are over Derrick
Henry's going to be we're going to look
back on Derrick Henry and go and he was
a dinosaur yeah but almost like Adrian
Peterson yeah but but special and unique
right like there were not other Adrian
Peterson's running around at the time
that he was doing it there aren't other
Derrick henries right you see guys you
know say Juan Barkley's involved in the
passing game you know there are guys
that are leaned on more than others but
no one's doing what the Titans have done
with Derrick Henry in terms of usage but
explain to me
the the Giants were negotiating against
themselves with Daniel Jones yes why not
just French no nobody was going to trade
for Daniel Jones or give up two
first-round picks for Daniel Jones and
they paid more for him they could have
used that money for saquon Barkley then
you know you could keep everybody happy
because Daniel Jones is going to be
successful if saquon Barkley is
successful I agree with every single
word you just said I think they
stretched too far for Daniel Jones I
think you know I I do think when you
look at where they come from right the
GM and the coach come from Buffalo they
never paid a running back there they
they use different guys I don't think
they're I don't think they're that
comfortable with the idea of of
committing
whatever 12 13 million a year to say
Juan Barkley I just don't think they
feel now they may recognize he's a
special player and in this case we need
to do it because of his importance to
Daniel Jones Etc but that doesn't mean
they're necessarily excited about doing
it right so uh yeah I think if they had
franchised Daniel and focused on signing
Sequon then they might have been able to
sign him by now but that also may have
been for a number that they just don't
think they should have to pay a running
back great to see you thank you for
stopping for having me this is great Dan
Graziano ESPN national NFL Insider he'll
be hosting NFL live today at four
Eastern we'll take a break David Cohn at
the top of the hour back with your phone
calls after this